since Kevin Hart bailed from the Oscars
the awards show is desperately seeking
new options including going without a
host at all now think about that the
Oscars looked around at all the
possibilities in their own it offensive
morally pure industry and they decided
you know what it's just not worth it
we're all jerks clowns sinners bigots
and pigs and of course we're petrified
of the mob meaning they're actually
human and just as every human has a
skill or talent we all have a past or a
life one worth more than a tweet but for
some a simple dignified apology will
never be enough the moral majority is
now the mobbing morality and forgiveness
is viewed as an accessory to evil and
the Oscars is responding the way
everyone does now to be so gun-shy about
the social media fallout that they just
give up and give in no one wants to
share the risk so nothing too edgy and
humans are just that in the face of
unforgiving hordes so after decades of
filling that hosting position humans
need not apply
so who then how about deep blue.the
chess-playing computer it's cold
faceless and never told a joke offensive
or otherwise ever much like Seth Meyers
or how about a drone something that can
drop a crude joke from on high then
completely disappear like Michelle wolf
but whoever they pick will be hosting
the show from under a rock or under the
rock unless of course they find someone
with guts who's not afraid according
scandal who could that be
[Music]
that's my choice but yeah I'll take the
risk people don't want to take the risk
so it's like even the Oscars to me it's
like any business they're like you know
we don't want any trouble you know and
they step away and then they just kind
of like talk about picking up your ball
and going home yes that would mean
though that we wouldn't have to do a
show about the Oscars to talk about
movies we haven't watched right that's
true whenever we do a segment we pretend
that we actually watched no we don't
pretend we don't pretend at all remember
it was just like two weeks ago that Joy
Behar was frustrated at the Country
Music Awards because they didn't make it
political right you can't have said
anything offensive it's the day you
could say something political as long as
it's offensive to half the country
exactly that's the point I should have
put in my monologue dammit I thought it
was a very good monologue one of your
best actually I think you should
probably take more days off to refresh
yourself because coming up with
monologues day after day that's why you
get the thin ones once a while this was
good this one was really good I don't
really have much to add I will see
people in film and art and Hollywood
these are supposed to be the creative
people with expression and not afraid to
take risk and they're the most uptight
squares ever they've ruined the Oscars
they did the same thing with the White
House Correspondents Center it got too
edgy for them they blew it and then they
now there's a historian up there instead
of a comedian at that political
correctness is literally ruining comedy
Mauryan why don't they you know I know
that's right that's right even worried I
do have a shrine in my office I was on
your show when the guy was like the who
was it remember the lady that he was
like the lady on the other end of the
camera
but you were also on special report -
yeah you know why not create a host
Pixar hologram the whole damn thing yeah
I don't care about the Oscars okay do
care about which I want the Oscars get
to continue cuz I love the fashion
segment at the beginning I watch the
Oscars because I I'm so girly like I
love seeing the women coming out in the
gowns I love the earrings and the
fashion and the hair doesn't have to be
girls
you're so sis normative what get the men
wear the dresses I actually don't know
it's me witnessing the death of
forgiveness for mistakes like I know you
guys did the segment yesterday about the
Heisman Trophy winner about a tweet from
when he was 14 right and it's like Kevin
Hart you know he already apologized and
they met apologize again what are the
comedian's I think Kevin by the way you
said Kevin Hart bails I don't think
Kevin Hart bailed on them I think they
were very reluctant to defend Kevin Hart
yeah that's what he said that's gonna
feed the social media friends and he
apologized again
what are you pologize but you know what
it wasn't real apology in the center I
think it was sincere in the sense that
he said he evolved and lots of people
have evolved on this question of
homosexuality in life right so what's
the big deal here once he said that but
yeah but the the way that the Twitter
social media universe works is it's
unending and it is unforgiving right but
I will say then in response to your idea
that we give Max Headroom the job it
would be the highest rated though ever
of course but you'd have to have like a
computer graphics and I suspect to play
to Morgan's theme have the person dress
in unusual ways and say edgy things yes
yeah we could go back we could go back
to like Redd Foxx and Mitch who's that
great comedian Mitch Hedberg yeah that's
right
you know how they came back we were at
the Reagan Library the other day and our
friend Brett Baron and Chris Wallace and
I and they have now Reagan as a hologram
like you know how Michael yeah they got
Reagan as a whole Howard Stern that was
radio show lately I listen to it all the
time
I thought you know I'm sure but I'm just
thinking boy you know for a woman to
hear this kind of wide range of
interests she does sailors say a lot
worse I think we need to bring
forgiveness back you have to make
forgiveness my point was like three
weeks ago we had den Dan Crenshaw right
everyone said that's the model for how
we should handle it everybody today
there was a case right in Texas a guy
attacked a woman right and then the
judge says 400 bucks
you know when some communities I'm like
that's outrage I don't think I'm a hard
man but yeah it's gracious the same
thing that is a execute of a crime and
he said I just think that's that's one
where I would say you know what hang in
judge time yeah but I mean that's I'm
talking about for tipping over tweet I
think there's